[Musique]
depuis des décennies le concours miss
france nous est présenté comme la
réalisation d'un conte de fées d'un rêve
magique auquel nous pouvons assister
chaque année entre beauté douceur et
bienveillance de savoir qui décroche la
couronne de miss france sauf en
coulisses il semblerait que leur est
fantastique se transforme souvent en
cauchemar bien réel ces derniers mois le
témoignage de plusieurs participantes
laisse penser que participer à miss
france ce n'est peut-être pas que du
bonheur l'année dernière déjà entre les
30 miss l'ambiance ne semblait pas être
au beau fixe comme l'admettait sylvie
tellier
c'est rare que je sois obligé de prendre
la parole deux ou trois fois pour dire
les filles c'est une aventure humaine
soyez gentils c'est principalement de la
mauvaise reimar haderer avec des
tentatives de déstabilisation
pire encore que l'ambiance certaines
miss reste traumatisée après différents
problèmes rencontrés lors des concours
régionaux comme annabelle gumbs virer
cette année à cause de photos dénudées
les photos c'est un grand classique des
polémiques chez les miss mais pire que
ça certaines d'entre elles ont du mal à
se reconstruire psychologiquement
notamment à cause des critiques parfois
violentes
certaines me sont même boycotté à cause
de magouilles que l'on peine à
comprendre alors magouilles traumatisme
le concours miss france est il dangereux
charlotte bob et ornella bello ratti
2000 qui ont rencontré des problèmes
avec l'institution miss france sont avec
nous pour tous nous dévoiler sur les
coulisses du concours le concours miss
france peut-il être dangereux et on à
charlotte avec nous charlotte bob
bonsoir charlotte magnifique un bravo et
ornella belotti magnifique également
alors merci d'être là et j'aurai un
petit truc à vous dire sur miss monde en
un instant je vous dis ça peut être
chaud pour miss france normalement ça
doit se dérouler le 19 décembre mais ça
peut être chaud chaud à seulement 18 ans
charlotte vous remportez votre premier
concours vous aviez décrocher votre
ticket pour participer à miss nord pas
de calais ouais et finalement devenir
première dauphine de nord pas de calais
en 2015 sauf qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
que des bons souvenirs du concours 1
voyez les narbonnais vous ça vous dirait
pas de vous présenter à miss france pas
du tout mais pas du tout c'est pas moi
d'aller dire non mais il m a regardé
cette émission je comprends que ce soit
la façon de planifier après je n'aime
pas trop le concept qui est la plus
belle et tout moi ça vous choque pas qui
est la plus belle
non moi je les aime toutes tu comprends
pas trop le alors jusqu'à que vous aurez
disposé du mal ont justement vous allez
voir est dans ce que je vais vous dire
tout à l'heure il ya beaucoup de gens
qui rejoint de l'ena et vous allez voir
ce qui peut se passer
pour miss france alors charlotte vous ça
a été un mauvais souvenir
c'était en fait une
belle expérience de vie vraiment faut la
vivre ma après jean 15 g en garde pas
tellement un bon souvenir parce que avec
l'injustice que j'ai pu vivre c'est quoi
la justice parce que en fait pendant mon
année
donc j'ai été élue miss pévèle est donc
en route pour la régionale mai
allez je vais dire
quatre mois avant on savait qu'ils
allaient très lus en fait coacher quoi
c'était déjà joué c'était way we s'était
déjà joué parce qu'il y avait des en
fait j'ai pas de preuves exact mais ça
se ressent m ça se ressent c'est à dire
que je finisse l'année ce qui a été élu
à l'époque avait été coaché directement
par le coiffeur attitré du concours miss
france
ouais ouais ouais bah comme benhaim ici
un mois je suis là voilà et ça déjà ça
voilà vous pensez qu'il ya des tuques on
pensait qu'une petite magouille
oui bah complètement il ya une magouille
oui c'est dommage en fait moi ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai sortie directe de le
lendemain de la régionale c'est qu'en
fait c'est dommage de booster une fille
dans l'est ces 20 dans la frustration
derrière dans ce cas je comprends pas
qu'on mette personnes soit enfin on
voudrait mettre tout le monde sur le
même piédestal et pas en booster une
danse nos qu'on aurait basé
c'est ce que disait un peu les lie à un
instant valdes en d'autres mots vous
dites c'est sois belle et tais toi
oui oui et c'est ça qui n'ont pas aimé
ça sans doute parce que moi il était
violent il est hors de question que je
laisse passer un truc comme ça away est
hors de question mais vous avez laissé
passer quoi parce que là c'est quoi les
preuves parler les petites steen que
vous avez à part le coiffer j'ai voulu
montrer à tout le monde que fallait
ouvrir les yeux c'est la la la miss qui
a été élu l élu depuis quatre mois elle
le sait elle même donc elle a été
boostée elle a été boostée de sens parce
que quand elles soient élues elles
soient directes mise en avant pour miss
france voilà elles soient préparés pour
miss france directement
je pense que l'on devrait tout tout nous
préparer bah parce que voilà après c'est
dommage de se rendre compte la miss
france peut-être la fille qu'on a choisi
qu'on a boosté bas ne valait pas ce
qu'elle veut aller à la régionale alors
vous on est là belotti
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
vous êtes magnifique aussi en 2015 alors
que vous étiez miss toulouse avait été
destitué pour une raison que vous avez
toujours contester vos tatouages
alors j'ai pas été destituée parce que
la couronne et les charges de l'est
toujours d'accord j'ai été disqualifié
de la deûle élections régionales parce
que j'étais tatouer le comité me
reprochent entre guillemets de ne pas
leur avoir dit que je t'ai tatoué sauf
qu'ils étaient au courant
j'ai trois écharpes dans le comité donc
j'ai été élue miss albigeois 2014 et
4ème dauphine miss midi-pyrénées 2014
donc
à sa fin chaque pré sélection ils
demandent si on les a tous et si on est
percé donc il le savait et pompe
énormément parce que dans la règle on
n'a pas loin d'être tatoué mettre
d'accord alors pas que ce soit au niveau
du décolleté ni du coût du final
d'accord ok vous aviez ce tatouage là
qu'on voit un peu oui oui ça passe pas
mais c'est lui là j'ai envoyé une photo
normalement il est il ils disent qu'il
faut pas qu'il soit vu par par le public
et ses tatouages et là ils étaient
camouflées parce que des miss qui en
fait miss france en ayant des tatouages
camoufler j'en connais donc mais vous
vous dites que vous dites vous dites
donc comme donc charlotte vous dites que
qu'il ya de la magouille de miss france
ouais c'est à dire penser que voilà il
ya des miss qui sont déjà choisis à la
danse alors dans mon élection en 2015 on
va dire beaucoup me suis amusé toulouse
donc je savais un peu que j'étais là
favorite pour m parce que j'avais déjà
des écharpes
ben quoi oui donc une fois qu'on est élu
et qu'on a des écharpes et bonnets
écharpes et vous envoie des écharpes
burberry mais c'est l'écharpé cris miss
toulouse miss albigeois ray vous envoie
déjà des écharpes commun avant même
d'être élu mais non ils s'étaient déjà
élu j'espère déjà bien dire magouilles
des hyènes magouilles des chapelains
vous expliquer très bien il ya 2 il ya
deux niveaux ayant fait l'élection
régionale élections nationales comme en
fait les magouilles c'est plus au niveau
régional parce qu'en fait il ya des des
responsables de régions à dire qu'ils
sont très influents et les intervenants
d'accord mais on va plutôt préférer une
chic une relance par exemple dans la
région nord pas de calais sert à cordes
la voie d'accord c'est ça mais en fait
donc c'est eux qui décident un petit peu
de représenter leur région oui si je ne
m'abuse
non vous ne vous abusez par miss nord
pas de calais en 2015 élue miss france
c'est camille sert exactement c'est 2016
mon année à douala parce que vous avez
j'ai fait la régionale j'ai été élu
mister bell 2015 pour faire la régionale
de l'insee c'est le rythme haricots
merci elle connaît toutes les missions
tu peux y aller même au niveau national
je sais pas si on peut parler de
magouilles mais vous savez quand on fait
une émission où le public vote pour des
candidates la production peut évidemment
mettre en avant certains candidats déjà
l'heure à laquelle est diffusé les
portraits en ses capés du monde devant
la télé à tel ou tel moment de
l'émission la tenue le maillot demain
qu'on m'a donnée à telle ou telle règle
c'est facile pour une production dans
n'importe quelle émission que ce soit
secretstory miss france peu importe où
le public vote pour des candidats ils
arrêtent les votes quand ils veulent
voilà d'avantagé tel ou tel candidat
c'est facile oui rené à bastien lui
spécialistes mais non spécialistes j'ai
tapé la barre thomas bien qu on
travaille les sujets variés avec le
sujet et j'ai beaucoup vu que des mecs
influent homme plein de pognon acheter
les jurys charlotte elle balance tout
j'adore / je veux dire aucun nom mais
bien sûr ça c'est à dire comment ça se
passe mais bien sûr ça il ya de l'argent
qui passe sous les tables mais c'est
dans les comités miss france c'est à
dire 'on va lyrique du plaisir quoi moi
quand on partage on le savait dès mon
jeune fille d'honorine disant je vais te
machy soit mise en avant
je suis un notable de la région elle
voudrait que oui je suis le maire
d'appel où ça c'est grave de dire ça
mais voilà la voile avant d'arriver au
dessus webb à ce qu'on aurait compris
donc quoi c'est vrai c'est déjà arrivé
ça ah oui bien sûr mais vous le saviez
déjà des miss qui vous ont dit on a pris
un petit billet pour on savait qu'on
allait on allait on allait passer de
mobilité vachement grave quand même oui
c'est nicholas reader
c'est un scandale ça oui un énorme
scandale qui remet en cause quasiment
mismari qui est un mec qui a donné des
voitures c'est vrai ch'ti ce nouveau nom
en fait c'est le papa de ma première
dauphine qui avait un garage du coup et
il prêtait les voitures au comité pour
transporter les miss élues tout ça mais
du coup c'est cette dauphine la cima qui
m'a remplacé à la régionale 2 acquis
grâce semble logique qu'il remplaçait la
titulaire oui sauf que dans les
dans de masques dans les votes dans les
votes quand on est élu il ya le vote du
public et de
du jury elle n'était pas dans les huit
premières au fait
alors oui n'était pas du tout un casting
pour être miss moi si je dis que j'ai
les abdos de cristiano ronaldo ils vont
mettre en slip ils vont voir si un truc
qui cloche
non je conçois je ne pense pas on la
honte a destitué pour un tatouage
prénommé en bas ils ont bien vu qu'elle
attache pourquoi ils l'ont laissé
continuer je sais pas tant que le mec
avec les voitures il arrive pour lui
dire maintenant tue le temps en bas âge
ou peut être un conte ou alors ça s'est
passé comme ça ils t'ont dit vas-y
adapté il ment il ment jamais rien dit
contre contre matthew hayes ont bien vu
le tatouage en maillot gagnent il ne
peut pas le cas mais quand lord et
dessiner le premier tatouage il était
camouflée non mais on défile et à
williams et les gens domicile
j'entends que fat documentaire sur miss
france qui passera sur ces huit tonnes
pas manqué le hold et sont absolument ça
peut être aussi facile de trafiquer les
votes dans ces élections parce qu'on est
d'accord qu'être miss france ça change
la vie d'une jeune femme elle a plein de
contrat après tu sais où c'est qu'il ya
seulement quelques milliers de votes
d'écart entre les prétendants dont je me
dis un sms à coups de quoi 2 euros si la
famille d'une miss l'entourage du miso
vraiment qu'elle gagne peuvent se
cotiser met 1000 2000 5000 euros et ça
peut faire basculer le résultat ça
change la vie d'une jeune femme
souhaitait un billet va cogner ça non
mais c'est vrai mais ça compte j'ai pu
me présenter l'année prochaine on ira
faire quand elles sont d'extraction plus
modestes elles sont pénalisées par
rapport à d'autres qui ne peuvent pas
payer qui sont moins populaires à mon
élection du cheval 2014 ya une miss k l
arrivée avec deux bus rempli oui c'est
si oui mais voilà qu'on apprend soir
guillaume ou qui avait fait un
documentaire c'est quoi les les
révélations basque on voit dans le
documentaire c'est que toutes les miss
france sur l'élection de deux téléphones
sont présentés de manière très lisse l
ont pas droit d'art de tatouage n'ont
pas le droit d'avoir fait des photos
dénudées et nous en ayant rencontré
toutes les miss après on se rend compte
que c'est des jeunes femmes normales qui
ont une vie qui sortons des amis qui
peuvent boire qui peuvent avoir des
relations amoureuses et c'est normal le
prennent du concours miss france c'est
que c'est un concours il ya cent ans qui
a 100 ans avec des règles 10 à 100 ans
et pratique aujourd'hui je veux vous
dire le concours dérange beaucoup
et moi je vais vous faire une révélation
soit sachez qu'il y a un très très gros
collectif qui est en train de se mettre
en place
deux jeunes filles qui vont tout faire
pour que miss france ne se fassent pas
le 19 décembre sont en train de voilà de
faire des pieds et des mains de vraiment
d'intervenir
au plus haut voilà pour que miss france
ne se passait pas ces tests c'est quoi
le 9 décembre et a déclaré qu'il a
raison c'est que il ya beaucoup de
filles qui pensent que c'est un concours
qu'on peut plus faire aujourd'hui je
jugeais des femmes sur leur physique les
les mettre sur un podium et qu'on puisse
est présenté au maillot de bain est ce
qu'elle se fasse jugé aujourd'hui je
vous le dis je peux pas vous dire les
noms jours lire jouera peut-être dès la
semaine prochaine
mais sachez que c'est en train de bouger
et que voilà il ya des gens qui sont en
train de faire pression pour que miss
france n'existe plus pour que le
concours miss france n'existe plus
bernard oui justement la beauté n'est
pas unique à caen ouvrir un peu ce
concours justement un des mises de
toutes les tailles et de tous les poids
cette fois pas an c'est ce qui m'est
après tout ça dommage je le fais de par
contre éliminés mais miss france bien
sûr de plein de petites filles et il n'y
a rien de rien de grave avec le fait de
faire des concours de beauté et c'est
toute une culture moi je connais plein
j'ai des copines et ou qui sont dans ce
délire là qui font les concours et où je
sais que c'est super cool et qu'il ya
quelque chose d'enrichissant qui fait
des aides etc
mais les critères de beauté ont
complètement changé c'est trop
restrictif l'émission moi je la regarde
pas spécialement mais je veux pas juste
voir des pieds faire un one two step
kickball shange bayeux et auprès d elle
et nous dire de frein sur le fait qu'
elles veulent faire ça ce serait bien de
2,2 évoluer le concours d'amener des
personnes de d'ouvrir un petit peu
qu'est le concours vivre avec son temps
aussi alors que l'état savait pas
si vous nous rejoignez sachez que le
concours miss france d'avoir du mal à se
tenir cette année en tout cas il ya un
lobbying qui est en train d'être faits
qui est très très important nicolas
pernikoff vous dire la gestion parce que
j'ai un truc avait d'anciennes miss
france aussi qui exactement a on est
d'accord c'est ça il ya d'anciennes miss
france également qu'ils sont en train de
faire grosse pression pour que le
concours est incroyable on n'est pas
pour que le concours n'est pas lieu le
19 décembre sur tf1 bernard et si jamais
ça a lieu le premier tableau ce sera
justement les 30 miss france et
maintenant elles seront pas 30
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de miss tahiti
60e anniversaire de tas de miss tahiti
est en fait il avait envie de délire un
miss tahiti avec du monde avec une
grande cette équipe comme ils ne peuvent
pas le faire ça va être repoussé au mois
de mai 2021
ça fait cinquante trois ans que ce n'est
pas arrivé ouais nicolas non moi j'ai
juste une question à vous poser si
c'était à refaire aujourd'hui vous vous
le referiez avec tout ce que vous savez
de miss france ou pas oui moi je pense
que je referai passé c'est une belle
expérience et que je crache pas dessus
sur l'autre et non avec tout ce que je
sais la main non non je leur ferai pas
non mais qu'est ce que vous savez en
fait les charlots voilà c'est le mal est
fait non c'est sur ce fond du court en
fait a lancé le fait d'en mettre une en
avant qui me qui me dérange vraiment
c'est que cellectis mais bien sûr on
peut vous a argué que c'est votre
sentiment que moi c'est sur un sentiment
d'intimité square en glace à 2 2 vous
avez fait des choses pour essayer
d'aller plus loin possible en moi j'ai
voulu abandonner les régionales une
semaine avant
ma mère m'a dit écoute fait là quand
même voilà y'a les corps il est prêté la
voiture de vêtements c'est ça
concrètement il a répondu vous avez vu
quoi qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous avez été dégoûté où vous
pouvez dire ce soir j'ai entendu des
choses dans les couloirs qui disait
avant même que la mise soit ému bon ben
c'est toi ce soir donc mais ça ne suffit
pas c'est pas une preuve
ah mais ça c'est pas une preuve mais je
parle en mon nom je sais ce que je sais
c'est à dire c'est quoi quand vous lisez
dans les couloirs il ya des
organisateurs qui sont allés voir la
miss alors que l'élection de me sauver
l'année c'est le savez la base à combien
s'élève la ville à la mi saison lundi
seront c'est moi qui gagne ce soir mais
ça se voit c'est la peau c'est la
personne elle est le fait ressentir ça
se voit tout le monde tout le monde qui
a fait la régionale avec moi en 2016
tout le monde peut le dire
les gens qui sont venus avec de l'argent
vous le savez ça y'en a marre régional à
la régionale oui avec de l'argent
ailleurs j'en sais pas non non non mais
j'avais dit un instant toutes les
données des pays qui avaient des choses
qu'ils prenaient des médecins voient le
délégué régional il est venu me voir
pour me dire à ce soir il y avait
beaucoup de monde
qui étaient là pour vous j'ai dit oui à
ma famille mais puisque ça enfin voilà
et ils savent très bien que plus on
ramène du monde plus on paye les entrées
et puis si à l'argent qui rentre on fait
dans l'horreur voilà mais après surtout
le truc qu'on a pris c'est ce que nous a
dit rooney c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
des vagues qui donnait des dessous de
table pour que telle ou telle me sois
élu a soulevé le lièvre mais je voudrais
dire entre kurt parce que
malheureusement on parle de soi
aujourd'hui si demain on parle d'autre
chose y aura les mets en rencontrent les
mêmes problèmes les gens soudoyer je
sais que dans le sport
et moi j'avais mon petit fils il avait
15 ans est allé faire une détection à 1
g -b
l'union paysanne à la fine de la delà de
la détection
il y avait des sorties et mes amis dit
l'entraîneur on me dit ah
le meilleur c'est lui je sais le garden
de saumur saison qu'il y est qui qui les
fait venir et le soir donc c'est lui qui
gagne un bon petit fidèle aux mines
accident le petit fils dans la voiture
me dis papy c'était joué d'avancé dit
pourquoi tu dis ça parce que j avais
réunis il me dit à la cathine à katyn
errani qui c'est qui doit arrêter ce
genre et lui la levée le droit guillaume
il ya un autre aspect dangereux du
concours miss france c'est que comme la
télé réalité en fait ils propulsent du
jour en main des jeunes inconnus de 21
millions de téléspectateurs n'ont qu'à
se retrouve très connu et après
contrairement à ce qu'on croit on pense
que quand on fait de la télé on est très
riche on gagne beaucoup d'argent mais en
a plein qui galèrent et d'ailleurs dans
le documentaire ordinaire d'un routier
on a parlé avec rachel legrain-trapani
sans nous a avoué qu'elle avait galéré
et qu'elle avait notamment chercher un
emploi de caissière et que ses
supermarchés halluciné simon prenait pas
les moyens à miss france qui cherchait
du taf
non mais c'est étonnant comme audrey
d'accord mais ça ça change aussi bien
grand scandale avec un photographe qui
prenait en fait toutes les filles jolies
en fait de france ouais avant qu'elle
soit élue miss france en fait des photos
très sexy et killer sortait après ça a
été le cas pour qu'elle voit kelly
bochenko mais ce rapport et c'est
vraiment grave et en fait il avait tout
un dossier comme ça
milliers de filles avec des photos sexy
kate ont sévi sur os 10 6 merci à elle
avait fait la couv des entrevues surtout
merci merci pour l'info